I've been to Israel twice once in 2019
when it was jam-packed with tourists and
once earlier this year when it was
completely empty now when I go to the
Church of the Holy Seiler or to the
temple mounts I prefer empty empty is
good not crazy about crowds so I can say
if you're planning to take a trip to
Israel at some point in your life this
is a really good time to take that trip
people think it's a bad time because of
rockets and such but if you want to
explore different sites that you read
about in the Bible now is the best time
to do it because there's no one at these
sites they're empty no crowds no
tourists but there's a downside to the
absence of crowds many small businesses
in Israel especially what we in the US
would call Mom and Pop shops depend on
tourism this past February AP and I
walked into a store
which was in the best possible location
in Jerusalem and we were the only
customers who came into the store that
day tourism is pretty dead right now but
again there are family businesses that
depend on tourism there are families
that make the jewelry sell the jewelry
they do it all it's how they survive so
one day October 6 let's say the Family
Jewelry business is
booming the next day there's a huge
attack then there's a war Rockets are
being shot out of the sky and no one is
showing up to buy any jewelry for a long
time if that store is your livelihood
and no one comes into your store how do
you buy food that's the situation for a
lot of small businesses in Israel and by
the way that's all part of the plan for
The jihadis Who start these wars we
always focus on the particular attacks
and then we forget about them after a
while but the attacks are part of a
long-term strategy they're not just
meant to spread fear for a few days
they're meant to destabilize communities
and weaken economies jihadis are willing
to take loss after loss after loss if it
helps them reach a goal 50 or 100 years
down the road fortunately there's a
really really easy way you can help
small businesses that have been
struggling in Israel while
simultaneously throwing a monkey wrench
into the long-term plans of
jihadis AP was asking about ways to help
while we were there and recently we were
contacted about a company that's helping
a lot of these mom and pop shops in
Israel right now the company comes up
with a new theme every few months they
gather products around that theme from
small businesses and charities in places
like Jerusalem and Nazareth and
Bethlehem and they send everything to
you in a box
some of the shops that contribute items
have said that if they hadn't been able
to send out products in these boxes they
would have gone out of business this
past year but let's open one and see
what they sent
me this is an artsa
box booklet on
top I'm going to pause to read this so
the booklet gives introduction to the
theme of the latest box it describes
some important archaeological sites like
the kumran caves and the pools of
Bethesda tells you about the items in
the box and who makes them there's a
recipe for red lentil stew because the
Box comes with the red lentil stew spice
mix even has a little Hebrew tutorial
hey Arts of box if you're watching this
because a bunch of my friends just
ordered your boxes I have a suggestion
when you have a Hebrew tutorial it would
be cool to include a link to your
website where we can hear someone
pronouncing the words very helpful for
people who like to hear exactly how the
words are pronounced all right let's see
what's in here red lentil spice mix made
by a farmer on the shores of the Sea of
Galilee bottle of anointing
oil frankincense and myrrh got a pack of
spiced roasted
cashews I had to open this pack but this
is a pack of prayer notes with Bible
verses on
them here's a mosaic pillow case
portraying the miracle of the Fish and
Loaves we've got
a wax
stamp with an image of an ancient coin
on
it this is a little Inkwell it's a
replica of the inkwells found in the
kumran caves where the Dead Sea Scrolls
are found and we have a kit for building
a wooden model of the Ark of the
Covenant according to the description
this kit is made by touchwood Design in
Jerusalem company creates employment
opportunities for individuals with
special needs at risk youth and soldiers
coping with
PTSD going to let my youngest kid do the
assembly this is the assembled wooden
model of the Arc of the Covenant I've
got a resting place for it right
here so that's an artsa box again they
change the boxes every few months you
can sign up to receive a box quarterly
four times per year you can cancel
anytime if you'd like some interesting
items from the Holy Land definitely sign
up if you want to get someone a present
maybe for
Christmas get them an artsa box they
have holiday themed boxes you get cool
stuff and you're supporting good causes
during difficult times and you're
helping thwart some long-term plans of
jihadis link to the website is in the
description box use the promo code
Dizzle to get a discount and to let them
know who sent you
[Music]